comment ça va aujourd'hui me regarder de
quoi je vous parle je vous parle de
casque comme ça alors souvenez vous
c'était il ya quelques mois au cs je
vous présentais alors je n'ai pas mis
sur youtube mais peut-être en short sur
tik tok sur un stage vous présentez un
casque de moto connectés intelligents
malin de la marque thalys marque
française très chouette et aujourd'hui
on est là pour en parler alors on est là
pour en parler à regarder on va se
mettre un peu plus larges et les deux
casques 2 proto qui sont alors attention
ce sont des casques qui vont arriver
c'est un casque c'est celui-là premier
proto deuxième proto c'est un cas ce qui
va arriver très bientôt d'ailleurs il ya
un kickstarter regardez bien jusqu'à la
fin parce que vous allez voir tous les
tarifs c'est extrêmement intéressant il
c'est pas n'importe quel casque c'est
vraiment un casque pour tous les
passionnés de deux roues passionné de
moto parce que on a de la sécurité on a
de la connectivité on a un truc est très
cool a d'un côté communautaire des
poires venir partager des datas vous
allez avoir plein d'informations sur
votre angle d'inclinaison sur la
sécurité ça fait alarmant fin bref
plutôt qu'il vachement intéressant
[Musique]
on a donc deux produits qui sont juste
là où celui là qu'on va regarder
aujourd'hui pour en parler on a le
fondateur de la boîte c'est issam viala
y salsa valse anne bonjour à tous mais
ça va très bien ravi d'être ici ben
écoute rabbit à voir avec nous alors il
sonne à fabriquer à fabriquer ce n'est
pas lui qui les a fabriquées en tout cas
il a réfléchi la conceptualiser des
castes tu seras là pour répondre à des
questions parce que j'adore une question
à poser surtout nous on va essayer de
comprendre il voir ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire avec ces cas scolaire je vous le
dis tout de suite si on en passe parce
que ces casques vont être dispo
kickstarter c'est à dire qu'ils vont
être disposées dire c'est quoi c'est une
sorte de prêt à châtrés commandes
exactement en fait c'est tout simplement
des préventes qu'on va lancer sur une
plateforme qui est basé aux états unis
ouais donc c'est un petit peu de crainte
forniquer encore une fois l'objectif
c'est tout simplement de proposer nos
futurs casque en avant première avec un
tarif bien sûr promotionnelle avec une
livraison ultérieure aucun hyper canaux
alors on va regarder je vous montrais
rapidement pour comprendre un peu
l'histoire ça c'est tout premier casque
c'était la v1 c'était la démo on a de la
lumière un peu de tous les côtés mais on
va râler sur le 2ème classe alors
attends on va les déplacer un peu comme
ça on va faire gars parce qu'on va pas
tout péter c'est ça quand même dommage
vu qu'on est sur les poteaux up attaque
celui nous intéresser c'est celui là
alors je vous explique un petit peu le
principe et d'histoire et casque est
vachement intéressant et s'il ya
plusieurs sujets qui motardes et motards
exactement au doute n'en dirai pas ça tu
roule sur une ducati streetfighter v4
est embauchée sur duke est aussi oui
mais pas comme toi monsters plus à la
coule tranquillement dans votre petit
virage fut bendardaf alors regardez en
fait l'idée c'est quoi l'idée c'est qu'à
l'arrière votre moto vous allez vraiment
la sinisation taina pourrait on faire
l'exact e mans en fait on a la
possibilité de faire une démonstration
regardez ça c'est cool c'est à dire que
ici là par exemple lorsque j ai freiné
avec médical je vais avoir un store
vraiment feux stop qui dernière se voir
derrière la tête donc le truc est
vachement bien en termes de sécurité et
en termes de prévention c'est qu'un
problème en fait et je regardais les
stades que tu m'as envoyé un fichier qui
était vachement bien fait c'est à dire
qu'en fait la plupart des accidents
qu'on va retrouver au niveau de la route
et bien c'est des accidents liés à la
bécane ya beaucoup de décès
malheureusement ça c'est toute crainte
vraiment donc l'idée c'est que lorsqu'on
vous vois bien et qu'on voit que lorsque
vous freinez que les automobilistes mais
veut bien parce que l'éclairage sera
vraiment en eau au niveau de la
signalisation et bien servir sauver des
vies et ça c'est vachement bien pour
qu'on va avoir ici le frein donc là je
freine hop il est allumé je vais avoir
aussi des clignotants c'est à dire que
lorsque je vais venir mettre à tourner à
gauche sur la droite au niveau de la
clio temps d'avoir une collection
directement grâce à un boîtier en
bluetooth et ça va venir s'afficher
directement sans mon casque donc là tu
nous fais tourner détricoter juste là
sur ton à gauche on le voit ici aussi
sur cette caméra autour de la gauche et
on va tourner à droite voilà de l'autre
côté ici voyant là aussi sur le côté là
ce qui fait que le truc on peut pas vous
mais qu'on ait une voiture derrière pour
les capteurs sur le côté on voit où est
ce que vous allez tourner donc ça déjà
c'est super bien le boîtier tu l'as fait
le voir pour fait ça c'est le petit
boîtier qu'on va venir brancher
directement dans syndicale alors vous
avez les différentes connectiques on va
le passer très rapidement le voiture est
ce qu'on était directement en bluetooth
avec votre casse donc là on a eu ni sim
à l'intérieur et il va se connecter
directement et votre smartphone si on
est à distance exactement en fait on a
l'avantagé d'avoir la ici mais aussi le
bluetooth qui permet de relier
directement sierra notre application
mobile donc via le smartphone et on a un
gps qui est complètement autonome et
indépendant qui va permettre d'avoir en
fait la position exacte à n'importe quel
moment et c'est d'attaquer collectés
elle va être transcrites donc via notre
application mobile et via aussi bas
toute la consommation de la 3g 4g en
fonction du raison donc le truc il ya
plusieurs bénéfices bénéfices numéro un
c'est la larme c'est à dire que tu as un
mec qui vient qui veut te piquer ta
bécane ça va sonner tata aussi le fait
pas le truc de la con à une alarme
sonore en fait de genre et si belle et
100 décibels autant vous dire que le mec
qui les secoue le monde a eu peut-être
un peu les oreilles donc ça c'est bien
et ça c'est super rassurant deuxième
point qui est intéressant c'est si la
moto elle tombe bien vous êtes alerté
exactement fait ce qu'on a mis en place
c'est tout simplement un détection du
moindre mouvement vous avez la chute
parking qui vous alerte via une
notification qui veut dire attention je
suis parking détecté sur votre moto ça
peut arriver comme des enfants jouent
près de votre moto bon bah voilà où
parfois quand on se gare notamment sur
paris que quelqu'un arrive et puis mais
sur une toute petite place et fait
tomber les autres motos donc voilà
l'idée c'est d'être avertis et d'avoir
les informations nécessaires pour
pouvoir avoir toutes les données
concernant là le moindre mouvement
suspect détecté sur sa moto j'ai vu
qu'on avait également l'accéléromètre et
le gyroscope dans le casque qui sont
dans le cas ce qu'ils ont pu sont pas
d'un beau tir ils sont dans la loi qui
remonte boîtier toute la technologie on
a essayé de la mettre sur ce dispositif
central pour alléger au maximum le
casque c'est à dire que rien aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir bien protégé sa moto on a
besoin des données de la moto donc
forcément lorsqu'on prend le casque avec
nous et qu'on à l'accéléromètre
gyroscope on n'est pas capable de
détecter tous les mouvements ou donc du
coup on a installé sur ce boîtier qui
était une formidable opportunité au
départ pour pouvoir récupérer les cris n
autorise feux stop et on a décidé en
fait d'avoir une vision sur la sécurité
mais de manière globale c'est à dire
vraiment à 360 la sécurité pour le tarn
et la sécurité aussi pour son bien c'est
à dire la moto ok donc ça ça veut dire
que déjà en termes de sécurité alarme
chute j'ai l'accéléromètre j'ai plein de
data sans la conduite pour voir si je
pilote bien ou pas si je fais n'importe
quoi ou pas tu peux venir j'ai vu qu'il
y avait aussi un système qui va arriver
deux communautés dans une communauté
italie où je pouvais revenir partager
avec tous les gens je pense autour de
moi alors on peut soit se faire des
balades en ce sens on peut venir
partager des dates un arrêt en sûr on va
mettre être capable en fait de proposer
ce qu'on appelle à un road book ou même
tout simplement un parcours à sa
communauté à son réseau mais aussi à des
gens qu'on ne connaît pas forcément
qu'ils vont être visible en fait sur la
communauté et ses salles avantage en
fait de l'application mobile c'est qu'on
est capable de constituer un réseau
communauté r et d'avoir la possibilité
en fait d'être visible ou pas au travers
de nos utilisateurs
hélas pas en fait une communauté qui va
permettre justement de définir des
balades entre amis des sorties des road
trip tout simplement quai alors il ya un
autre truc est super super canon c'est
en termes de sécurité c'est un axe qui
va seulement mis en avant à savoir qu'
il ya une grâce giraud score grâce à
l'accéléromètre grâce au gps grâce à la
4g on va pouvoir prévenir si jamais il
ya un accident ça veut dire que si je me
plante en décale il va quoi il va me
demander via mon téléphone est ce que
savard est ce que ça ne va pas
exactement en fait on a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle le système hi emergency
c'est tout simplement la prévention des
secours en cas de chute d'accident on
est capable aujourd'hui de définir grâce
à tous les composants électroniques tu
viens de citer tout simplement si c'est
un accident si c'est une chute parking
et quand on va faire la différence qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va contacter
l'utilisateur on va dire voilà pendant
30 secondes la plaie et savoir si tout
est ok si nous répond et qu' il a juste
à cliquer en disant bon bah voilà la
situation de contrôle le danger
maîtrisée et pas de problèmes en
revanche si on n'a pas de retour de sa
part ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on prévient
les secours on envoie la position exacte
aux services d'urgence et on est capable
de rassurer son entourage parce que il
l'aura préprogrammés et donc on pourra
rassurer sa famille ses proches en
disant attention voilà il ya un accident
qui a été détecté une chute qui a été
détectée les secours sont prévenus et
vont pouvoir intervenir ça veut dire que
s'il est un accident tu veux envoyer un
message à trois personnes pour des
regrets l'accident les secours arrivent
voilà sa position gps voilà qui m'ont
charrié exactement aux caisses il a
configuré sur l'application mobile oui
vaut mieux on les laisse on n'est pas
rentré ici pour parler du cas ce qu'on
lui met alors on pousse à traiter pour
l'instant le casque pour lui-même il est
juste là alors ça a effectivement ça un
proto ça veut dire que c'est pas le
casque définitif il ressemblera à ça
vous fait un nouveau casque avec un
moule en fibre de carbone exactement la
légèreté tout à fait ok pour la
résistance à l'abrasion pour toutes les
propriétés que cette matière que nous
fournir en terme d'accidents de chuter
en cas de besoin ok on vient le chargé
également aussi directement au volant le
poser sur son socle alors ça c'est quoi
c'est pas le définitive si leur celui
qui sait c'est comme l'est le définitif
c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est un socle
qui a la particularité c'est à la fois
de pouvoir poser son casque et de
l'orangé de manière un petit peu plus
esthétique mais un côté fonctionnel dans
k on a intégré en fait un petit ventilo
qui va permettre au delà de recharger le
casque ans et sa première fonction c'est
de pouvoir l'aérés parce que
effectivement autant s'inspirer compagne
d'écraser tallieu nous qui sont actifs
se mouiller et c'est bon tu le pose
c'est quelle jeunesse et esthétique et
ses pratiques halte à des infos sur la
batterie comme avant à l'intérieur mais
en fait on a une batterie donc
traditionnelle qui va être capable de
nous fournir une autonomie de 4 à 6
heures en chemin dont on va avoir le
bluetooth la connexion aux smartphones
avec aussi bas les lettres qui sont
complètement en full alu mais c'est à
dire complètement intégrée et on va
avoir donc l'intercom ah oui donc un atr
comme ça c'est aussi truc qui est
intéressant c'est à dire que lorsque
vous partez en balade eh ben on peut
venir communiquer avec ses amis
directement pas vendre acheter
d'intercom en plus on à l'intercom qui
est directement fournis à l'intérieur
donc ça c'est plutôt cool aussi au
dessus j'ai été intéressant c'est j'ai
vu que tu avais un assistant vocal alors
kakwata en cause la satisfont vocaux tu
peux dire paramétrer à qui un médecin
alexa google et si les séries des gazons
les trois en fait lorsque vous avez
l'application on est capable de
configurer le smart assistant qui va
bien fait de les réutiliser et l'
avantage c'est que vous utilisez la
commande vocale de manière intuitive
c'est ce qui permet aussi de piloter
tous vos actions de communication de
manière beaucoup plus sereine et vous
restez concentrés en fait sur la route
c'est vrai que tu lui dis ok je ne fais
pas bien parce que j'en ai plein ici là
c'est celle de sadac inédite aux
nouveautés dismoioù est la prochaine
nation par station pour me changer parti
peut lui demander de quoi d'appeler
quelqu'un tu peux demander de te mets de
la musique aussi du port a bien sûr
directement avec des haut-parleurs
exactement n'est capable de demander à
son smart assistant de jouer sa playlist
préférée centrale osmotique et où 10 à
10 ans et français je voudrais qu'on
parle aussi un peu de l'application
alors savait que pour l'instant elle est
en développement donc on n'a pas
l'application à vous montrer tout de
suite mais en fait le but de
l'application effectivement c'est de
voir toute la sécurité de voir ces
données de récupérer des stats mais ça
veut dire qu'en fait toutes ses stats ça
va servir à quoi ça va servir quoi
améliorer ton pilotage ça va me servir
uniquement à partager et imprimer ou
alors c'est un vrai sens quand et b côté
quand les motards ont fait alors en fait
cette application elle a pour objectif
je dirais d'innover le parcours
utilisateur du mode c'est à dire que on
est capable aujourd'hui dans un domaine
préventif de mettre en place des actions
telles que le prévenir les secours
rassuré son entourage ça c'est pour la
partie celtix dont la partie sécurité
mais pour la partie plaisir performance
on a développé une fonctionnalité qui
s'appelle le mode raïs le mode risque
est ce que c'est ça en fait lorsque vous
allez pratiquer la moto sur piste avoir
en fait de la donne et comme on peut
retrouver un petit peu sur le grand prix
avec des angles d'inclinaison des force
d'accélération de décélération donc la
force et j'ai une trajectoire le
meilleur chrono l'idée c'est
d'accompagner en fait ces gens là qui
recherchent la performance à développer
leurs progrès en leur fournissant des
statistiques et des données très
précises et qui vont permettre justement
soit d'exporter ça en fait sur leur
ordinateur et pouvoir analyser mais
vraiment de manière un peu comme les
anges et le front sur le grand prix soit
tout simplement par plaisir et par frime
avec ses copains ils ont donc voilà j'ai
réussi à accoucher la la la moto de deux
ans que le plus que toi j'ai vu monter
avec une force de géant qui est plus
importante que la jane éviter d'acheter
partir du clitoris et c'est pas lui
ok non mais c'est hyper canon se confond
avec timo et donc l'application en fait
nous sert à quoi nous sert à mettre en
place un système d'accompagnement parce
que derrière on a mis en place le
parcours digitalisées du suivi de
l'entretien de la moto c'est à dire
qu'on est capable aujourd'hui de vous
dire dans 500 km et voyez la révision de
votre moto dans 200 km pensé à faire la
vidéo ça comment ça se passe et ça c'est
toi qui dois rentrer les données avant
ou alors c'est la personne qui gère
l'entretien ta bécane qui veulent
rentrer directement au départ il va le
remporter il va mettre en place son
kilométrage qui ont aimé dans un futur
très proche on va être capable en fait
dentaire d'intégrer tous les modèles sur
notre application car il leur a juste à
choisir son modèle de moto mais la roja
voilà on aura toutes les données
constructeur qui sont libres d'accès
pour pouvoir justement paramétrer tous
sont son carnet d'entretien bon alors
moi il ya ceux qui m'intéressent jeu
qu'on parle dans le dur c'est
effectivement le kickstarter à savoir
qu'effectivement c'est un casque qui
devrait arriver normalement pour être
industrialisés pour ce par quoi on se
parle de deauville 23 à l'improbable
exactement tout à faire ça pour
l'instant c'est un poteau sur un joli
proto mais il pas en fibre de carbone
tout n'est pas finalisé ça va arriver
très bientôt et a commencé un trick en
ce projet et où on a commencé fin 2018
et toute cette phase d'idéation de
design conceptuel en 2019 fleuries 2010
stable déposer les statuts de
l'entreprise parce que bon ben voilà il
y avait quand même des factures qui
commencent à arriver très intéressant de
récupérer la tva est derrière très vite
on a mis en place en fait ce qu'on
appelle un peu le lean start up c'est à
dire que on se posait pas trop de
questions en mettant en place les
concepts les fonctionnalités on y
verrait on apprenait et on sait
constituer une communauté derrière
docteur qui a la faculté c'est que dans
ce projet c'est vrai que c'est un casque
y réaliser pour les motards mais avant
tout par des motards des gens qui nous
ont accompagnés qui sont passionnés par
cet univers est évidemment qui voulait
pas faire de compromis entre la sécurité
l'esthétique et puis la technologie ok
c'est hyper qu'elle alors moi je vous le
dise un truc est ce que vraiment
vraiment extrêmement intéressant je
voulais montrer j'avais vu au clsc
c'était dingue parce qu'il ya une énorme
communauté de motards sur les réseaux le
nombre de personnes qui ont suivi selon
k 1 million 3 de vue soit sur facebook
c'était dingue c'est à dire ça vachement
intéressés donc ça c'est un cas ce que
vous allez pouvoir on va pas dire
précommander mais quelque part on va
investir 1 d'être le kick start up et
lorsque le casque sera dispo bien je
vais pouvoir la voir alors regarder pour
l'instant les d'accès ça au 21 juin on a
le lunch des spéciales 999 euros alors
c'est un certain prix attendez on parle
d'un casque de moto non pas d'un objet
connecté on parlera d'objets
intelligents 999 euros quand on les sent
en perspective avec le prix d'un
smartphone très haut de gamme ça me
paraît pas du tout déconnant avec tout
ce que ça vient faire derrière alors
c'est quoi en fait parce que je vois que
j'ai le lunch des spéciales à 999 euros
et je vois que même jour j'ai de supers
orly a doctor c'est quoi la différence
que je comprenne en fait le lunch de en
fait spéciale il est réservé au sens
premier bakar ok donc et sur la première
journée c'est très limité donc là pour
ça qu'on a ce prix la 999e d'accord donc
laissons premiers ils ont ça et après on
prend soin euros de plus pour les dans
les superbes reliait docteur exactement
ça veut dire qu'ensuite deux jours après
on a les early adopters là c'est le 23
juin on passe à 1199 euros ça augmente
un peu et puis à partir du 25 juin c'est
le lancement officiel c'est ça c'est dit
pas de bêtise avec le cake starter le
prix kickstarter on sera 1299 ans ça
sera le prix du casque définitive quand
il sortira dans le c'est notre objectif
en fait dans cette industrie ce qui est
important de savoir c'est que on peut
réaliser de grosses économies lorsqu'on
a du volume est une des raisons pour
laquelle on laisse kickstarter c'est
pour définir justement ces volumes et
pour pouvoir arriver devant l'industriel
en disant bon bah voilà qu'on va être
capable de prendre telle commande dans
un premier temps et ensuite ajuster la
tarification forcément parce que
derrière il va y avoir des économies
d'échelle à ce niveau là ouais donc plus
on a devant lui et moi ça coûte cher
quoi exactement ok donc c'est hyper
cadres alors moi avons effectivement on
s'arrête à certains budgets mais vu ce
qu'on est capable de faire ça c'est sûr
que c'est un quinze qui se destine aux
biker technophiles qui veulent vraiment
un vent de la data qui veulent de la
sécurité qui veulent un objet avec un
objet connecté français ils sont
fabriqués ou ce casque en italie pour la
partie donc mécanique c'est à dire tout
ce qui est coque carbone on travaille
qu'à un partenaire carte 40 ans d
expertise dans ce domaine là dans la
conception et la production de casques
notamment quatre avec des grandes
marques qu'on peut pas hésité
malheureusement et pour toute la partie
hardware donc l'électronique s'est fait
en france ok dans nos industries et
l'intégration sera fait en france hyper
canon et toi ta boîte et les baisers ou
abu shreh dans le 78 en région
parisienne mais quand marie le franc de
froncer ita ita l'offre italienne aux
français ouais c'est ça l'idée on a on a
le design et la classe des italiens et
la technologie l'innovation des français
doit vous le savez alors voila moi je
trouve super canon dites moi ce que vous
en pensez en commentaires si vous avez
des avis des suggestions des
interrogations si vous avez les zombies
peut-être pour des versions deux
versions 3 versions car tu pouvais y
aller et je pense que j'écrive
internationaux oui exactement on est
tout ouïe et encore une fois ce projet
il est certes destiné aux motards mais
on souhaite avoir le concours justement
des des personnes qui sont intéressées
on est très ouvert à vos suggestions
donc n'hésitez pas un mais des
commentaires on sera ravi de vous
répondre en tout cas est ce un bien tu
voudras youtube pourquoi pas
on l'a dit ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire je trouve très cool j'ai
vraiment hâte que ce casque soit
industrialisés pour pouvoir aller sur la
route m'amuser un peu avec en tout cas
merci sam j'espère que ça vous aura
intéressé et n'oubliez pas de noter dans
vos agendas je vous mets le lien quelque
part à en bas de kickstarter pour aller
y jeter un oeil peut-être que vous
verrez cette vidéo une fois que
kickstarter sera lancée le lien est
quand même présent vous pouvez y aller
et puis bien évidemment suivre tally sur
les différents réseaux sociaux voilà
nous embrasse un bientôt pascal on les
remercie saluer très vite à bientôt sur
la route ouais ciao ciao
[Musique]